mathieu arsenault professeur d'histoire
bonjour bonjour ça vous étonne pas outre
mesure qu'on ait déboulonner la statue
de jean nemec en aussi il est une cible
facile ou quoi sa présence au sein de la
paix ce cadeau ici en fait une cible
idéale
vu que c'est un endroit que toujours été
pensée comme un lieu de rassemblement et
que le symbole qui investit dans ce
monument non seulement la statue mais
aussi le baldaquin et où le soft est peu
en phase avec les préoccupations
politiques quotidiennes ou contemporaine
est ce que c'est le début de la fin pour
tout statut du passé c'est intéressant
parce que l'oms loin en 1909 disait si
jamais on veut mettre que des faux des
statues de saints ou d'un parfait sans
tache nos parcs serait complètement vide
alors ce débat là il fait voyez fait
rage depuis très longtemps on est rendu
à une époque où le symbole qu'on a mis
sur et le mythe de mcdonald's du canada
colonisateur qui s'étend vers l'ouest on
est arrivé un moment où il faut le
repenser est-ce qu'il faut enlever
complètement le monument c'est koné
serment ce pour quoi je me mêle à la
ville de montréal dans un dilemme une
réflexion qui est très problématique
parce que si on l'enlève complètement
pour le mettre dans un musée on va avoir
des gens qui vont nous dire qu'on a
indiqué cet héritage la grandeur de
mcdonald's
si on le restera comme on l'a fait en
2010 et que ça nous coûte plus de 400
mille dollars
il va devenir il va continuer d'être une
cible pour les attaques de ceux qui
veulent changer le narratif mathieu
arsenault on va suivre
tout seul on va voir ce que la mer est
ce c'est la ville de montréal qui devra
trancher ce dilemme
merci beaucoup grand plaisir merci